das wort geht schon gar nicht mehr raus
weil wir es gewohnt sind lockerungen
also gibt es endlich lockerung auch das
ist die kanzlerin heute gefragt worden
nach dieser klaren perspektive für
deutschland und das bei ihrer anfahrt
also wir haben eine der letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz etwas
glaube ich wichtiges besprochen dass wir
eine öffnung perspektive entwickeln
wollen gemeinsam bund und länder und die
wird sich sicherlich nicht an einem
datum orientieren können sondern sie
wird sich an werten orientieren müssen
wie viele infektionen haben wir wie
sieht es auf den index
traditionen aus und vor allen dingen
auch welchen prozentsatz nimmt die
mutation ein die ja sehr viel
aggressiver die werte gehen
erfolgreicher erfreulicherweise runter
und das ist die leistung der bürgerinnen
und bürger und dafür will ich auch dank
sagen denn es ist ja so wie sie sagen
die nerven liegen blank man das ist eine
lange strecke es ist jetzt die schwerste
strecke noch durch diesen winter
das habe ich oft gesagt und wir haben
jetzt inzwischen wieder 50 land kreise
oder städte in denen die inzidenz also
die zahl der infektionen in sieben tagen
auf 100000 einwohner unter 50 ist wir
hatten zeitweise so gut wie keinen
solchen kreis dort sieht die sache
natürlich wieder anders aus als da wo
wir eine instanz von 200 haben das heißt
wir wollen dass die gesundheitsämter
wieder die nachverfolgung der kontakte
machen können damit uns die zahlen nicht
wieder ansteigen denn eine öffnung für
14 tage bei der wir anschließend wieder
in ein exponentielles wachstum kommen
wieder die intensivstation stärker
belegt sind wir reicht die lösen wir
brauchen einen nachhaltigen weg aus der
pandemie was denken millionen menschen
die heute dieses interview nach und nach
sehen werden wenn sie diese äußerungen
hören die gucken vor allen dingen wenn
sie kinder haben auf mögliche
schuleröffnung die gucken wenn sie
gastronomen sind auf restauranteröffnung
und so weiter und so fort was denken die
was glaubst du paul bei diesen
äußerungen der kanzlerin ich glaube sie
sind alle genervt mittlerweile vom lock
down und auch sicherlich genervt von der
politik dass es keine klaren ansagen
gibt dennoch glaube ich wenn man sich
auch die werte in der bevölkerung
anschaut das ist immer noch ein großes
vertrauen in angela merkel als
krisenmanagerin gibt was den lockdown
angeht wenn man sich die zahlen anschaut
ist für mich erstaunen
ich das immer noch so eine große
mehrheit sagt wir sind für die harten
maßnahmen bis zuletzt waren sogar noch
wenige für noch härtere maßnahmen also
deutschland scheint sich so ein bisschen
entwickelt zu haben in eine richtung
dass man das gut findet wenn hier ist
länger und will hart wenn hatte haarde
regiert hatte ansagen gibt
das ist momentan aus meiner sicht immer
noch die mehrheit dennoch dass man so
gar keine aussagen trifft und das ganze
weiterhin sozusagen richtung mutationen
schiebt und immer wieder sagt naja wir
müssen schauen was mit dieser mutation
passiert da wäre es jetzt mal schön weil
die mutation gibt es ja schon eine zeit
ja wir werden das dezember wurden flüge
aus großbritannien gecancelt dass man
uns endlich sagt wie gefährlich denn
jetzt diese mutation ist und daraus
schlüsse zieht ich glaube damit wird die
kanzlerin nicht lange durch kommen wenn
die zahlen so bleiben wird es eine
öffnung strategie geben es wird druck
geben von der spd das höre ich bereits
aus dem hintergrund vor allem wird druck
geben dass kitas und schulen geöffnet
werden aber zum abschluss man muss sagen
das ist die kommunikationsstrategie der
kanzlerin von anfang an
sie ist immer die vorsichtig vor sehr
sehr vorsichtig und sie ist selbst dann
glaube ich vorsichtig aus rhetorischen
gründen aus kommunikations gründen
selbst wenn sie denkt wir müssen öffnen
bleibt sie noch vorsichtiger damit die
ministerpräsidenten am ende nicht sagen
wir wollen noch mehr also nehmen wir an
die ganz kurz benehmen an die kanzlerin
sagt macht die schulen auf sie will halt
nicht dass dann die ministerpräsidenten
sagen macht aber jetzt auch die
restaurants auf also dass auch viel
taktik dabei
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren